[Music]
oh oh walkie-talkie walkie-talkie okay
we've spent ten years keeping up with
the kardashians
and now the famous family is spilling
secrets behind some of their shows of
most famous moments to The Hollywood
Reporter I mean I really cared more
about the business and running our
clothing stores at the beginning and
more the business behind it thinking
like oh we'll do a reality show because
it'll bring attention to the store and
to the business so I always have that
mindset here's seven things we learned
about the show from the people behind it
one II originally passed on the concept
executive producer Ryan Seacrest
threatened to take it to Bravo and
that's when network execs changed their
minds to the show's title was an
accident a VP of the production company
said he was quote too busy keeping up
with the kardashians to actually come up
with the title and well the rest is
history
that's it we're done three Courtney
wasn't on board with the show at first
she admits she would hide in the
bathroom to avoid cameras and a for
Chloe hated filming her spin-off Khloe
and Lamar but went along with it
because it was according to her Lamar's
idea what my sister said I'm not my
husband five is Kim's pick for the
hardest episode to film the about Bruce
special
she says they actually edited out some
of Khloe's reaction because she was
quote so upset to tell your kids okay
six Kim says she gets Kanye West's
approval of any footage used of him on
the show in fact for number seven Kim
claims that of all her sisters she is
the biggest producer and will
to cruise over to their houses when she
thinks something is going on it's not
just about you know doing a show and
having a camera follow you around
it's everything that happens after
[Music]
you